welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and dr. strange that a wizard and
endless well a mystery was left in an
interesting state by the events of
Avengers endgame and infinity war with
the filmmakers revealing alternate
sanctum sanctorum scenes removed from
the film and the bonkers truth with
Strange's unique perception of the
Marvel timeline that leaves us wondering
it's strange okay like what kind of made
him to be okay it's just this next movie
has madness in the title or just feeling
a bit uneasy that is old mental
condition so I'm gonna break down all
the big reveals about Doctor Strange and
endgame and what they could tell us
about Doctor Strange and the multiverse
of madness and spoiler warning any case
to reveal too much and ruin your life
just like strange his life is ruined
okay first we recently learned about a
deleted scene concept from the in-game
infinity war screenwriters Marcus
McFeely Eminem about an alternate
version of the time heist that would
have taken the Avengers inside the
sanctum sanctorum in a scramble for the
time stone they said at one point we had
a different way of getting to the time
stone which involves some characters
breaking into the sanctum sanctorum and
being pursued by all the weird stuff
that happens to be trapped inside there
it was totally our story and unnecessary
and it got cut but it was fun though
right yeah so this sounds like it was
from the removed time heist sequence
that the writers had previously referred
to in which rather than going back to
the Battle of New York in 2012 a group
of Avengers went back to the Triskelion
and they said that would have led to the
Avengers jumping in a car and driving to
dr. Strange's house and now Eminem are
suggesting that that led cap Stark Hulk
ant-man whoever else threw a goofy time
stone wizard scramble through the
sanctum sanctorum where being someone
Mordo Wong maybe the New York sanctums
former occupant master drum attacked him
with crazy magic and artifacts home
alone style and we actually got a hint
toward this old draft in the Ancient
Ones warning to Hulk I'd be careful
going that way we just had the floors
waxed so just imagine the Avengers
flipping around on a sink the floor open
portals for them to fall through forever
getting smothered with a cloak of
levitation and the crimson bands of
cyttorak a swinging culture the cosmos
had smashed it in their faces
but this awesome alternate scene would
have left out a key moment relating to
Stephen strange which came up in the
final version looking for Doctor Strange
you're about five years too early
Stephen strange is currently performing
surgery about 20 blocks that way so this
reminds us of dr. Strange's origin as a
physician trying to heal himself and
this healing arc got another nod at the
end of the film if you're looking
closely as strange held up one finger to
tell Tony Stark that this is a one
Victoria's future he saw his fingers
trembles a reminder of the lingering
physical damage to dr. Strange's hands
and now the directors have actually
given another reveal about Strange's
health this time his mental health in a
QA this week answering a question that
didn't send us all in a wild goose chase
and search for a nova Easter Egg that
didn't exist I'll talk about that but
before I continue this video was
sponsored by expressvpn a VPN allows you
to browse the internet with privacy
without things like ad companies hackers
spyware any of these nefarious entities
tracking your data secretly filtering
your Internet experience expressvpn
masks your IP address to make sure you
aren't being monitored so you can have
that peace of mind you can live life
knowing no one is using an infinity
stone powered perception to peep on you
personally I use Express VPN because
like I don't want the Internet assuming
I'm obsessed with Benedict Cumberbatch
just because I spent several hours
searching for dr. strange topics and
watch that goofy footage of him as Smaug
I should be able to rewatch that without
ending up on a list somewhere in
expressvpn is the fastest VPN on the
market the number one VPN service rated
by TechRadar in say you're in a
different country you might not be able
to access everything on Netflix or
YouTube other streaming services yeah
that feels wrong but thanks to express
VPN you could have waived all those
weird restrictions you can just watch
everything that you want to watch
normally the way the Internet should be
wherever you are
expressvpn lets you securely stream or
download content from anywhere anytime
it's less than $7 a month folks with a
30-day money-back guarantee take back
your internet privacy today and find out
how you can get three months free just
by clicking the link in the description
box expressvpn comm slash new rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash new
rockstars
for three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn comm slash new
rockstars to learn more take back your
net privacy today
okay back to the Russos statement about
dr. strange strange has to exert an
immense amount of energy into going to
go into this state he could be in that
in that state for who knows how long so
it could have taken strange an immensely
long time to actually
review all these scenarios it's a
physically lived them you know and then
died in each of them and right before he
dies he has to reset it as we saw at the
end of Doctor Strange and and do it
again and take copious notes each time
he does it
Wow so the directors are confirming that
dr. strange lived through each of the 14
million 605 alternate futures that he
foresaw so how old would that make his
mind
well imagine each of those futures took
about an hour from the moment strange
began his time stone assisted trance to
the moment he dusted away that would be
14 million 605 hours and at least that
because a number of those also probably
would have led strange to experience
more time after he really confirm Hulk's
map on the other side but in this
scenario we're looking at roughly 14
million six hundred and five hours
divided by 24 hours a day and again by
365 days a year that equates to about
1600 years that strange his mind lived
through and that would be on top of the
unknown amount of time strange lived
through while in the time loop wearing
down Dormammu now the screenwriter said
that strange died somewhere between a
few dozen and a few hundred times with
each Dormammu encounter ranging seconds
to several minutes maybe even hours in
some of those now in some
interpretations of that movie
the Ancient Ones earlier line about
stretching one moment out into a
thousand was foreshadowing strange dying
a thousand times however you crunch it
it is possible that Stephen strange his
mind is over 2,000 years old that would
make him the true ancient one for a
human mind to experience that much has
got to leave a mark remember there was
that episode of black mirror that
explored how trapping a human
consciousness in a limbo state for
thousands and thousands of years
considered torture leads to insanity
maybe that is what the madness of the
upcoming Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness is referring to
imagine what this man has lived through
millions of life ending moments taking
up a total watch time of millennia with
not just his own death but a front row
seat to others dying as well over and
over in seemingly endless filing forms
perhaps even the dark alternate in deeds
the writers conceived with Thanos
cap severed head sitting on a throne of
skulls the corpse of giant man Fester's
in the background like at best Stephen
strange would be numb desensitized from
these experiences but at worst he would
be traumatized and haunted to his core
this dark state could be where we find
strange in the multiverse of madness
perhaps the title refers to the danger
of win a sorcerer as powerful as Doctor
Strange has had his mind shattered that
vulnerable state could be how he becomes
the target of the demonic entity that
many have suspected will be the villain
of the multiverse of madness nightmare
nightmare is the entity who resides in
the dream dimension who feeds off the
negative emotions of human consciousness
'as remember at the end of the Doctor
Strange film
Mordo Ward strange about the
consequences of meddling with time loops
like this then we just assumed that he
was referring to cosmic threats like
Thanos but really Mordo was more likely
referring to darker dangers that lurk in
once the human mind has stretched itself
to a breaking point pain may be an old
friend to Stephen strange but there are
all kinds of pain that he is an
experienced yet do you think dr. strange
has been traumatized by the events of
infinity war an endgame or do you think
his mind is strong enough to withstand
all this comment down below with your
thoughts and theories follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at 8 boss and
subscribe to new rock stars for more
breakdowns and theories but everything
Marvel thanks for joining me and if pain
is the game for multiverse of madness
Rob Zombie's still needs to score this
movie
[Music]